en el estado de nueva york las
autoridades están en alerta
mucha gente pensaba y continúa pensando
que los niños no eran afectados por el
cob it es falso
porque las hospitalizaciones de niños
afectados por el cob y de en eeuu están
en gran aumento eran más de 260 por día
en ser admitidos en los servicios de
pediatría para la semana del 24 de
diciembre o sea un aumento de 30% en
comparación a la semana anterior en
nueva york' las admisiones de niños se
han cuadruplicado lo que preocupa a la
población en plena temporada navideña
siento que pudiera ser alguien de mi
familia en especial las personas que
están enfermas y ya sabes son mayores y
ahora los niños hay que tener cuidado y
6 pero en el estado la mitad de los
niños admitidos en pediatría tienen
menos de 5 años y por lo tanto no están
vacunados